Florida's governor says more than 1800
rescue workers are already helping with
the recovery and the cleanup the hardest
hit areas include the coastal towns of
Port st. Joe and Mexico Beach where
Michael made landfall Omar Villafranca
is in Port Saint Joe which was cut off
for hours at the height of this terrible
storm
Omar good morning good morning Gail just
getting in and around Port Saint Joe is
an adventure in itself so people who are
brave enough to try to come back here
some of the residents and business
owners this is an example of what
they're seeing a home like this windows
blown out you have a lot of debris in
the yard from the walls from the roof
everything just ripped down and thrown
it let me take you over here we have
trees in the street this is partially a
residential area you have this home over
here looks like it's okay but there is a
lot of water that was flowing through
this area we saw a water line that was
maybe two or three free we were actually
hunkered down in Port st. Joe when
Michael was blowing through the walls
were shaking the ground was shaking he
was pretty vicious we were wondering
what that damage would look like here is
another piece of the damage we want to
show you this is a business I'm gonna
try to get out of here with the shadow
the wall is gone there's no longer a
wall there the roof is gone and part of
the contents of this fast food store or
basically spread three four blocks out
in this neighborhood it is a lot of
damage a lot to cleanup and the cleanup
process is just getting underway
we don't have radar we don't have cell
halls after the eyewall past Fort Saint
Joe those who wrote out the storm emerge
to find the town shredded by the
hurricane
boats were pushed onshore trees snapped
in half by 155 mile-per-hour winds
power lines hung over roads and cars
were crunched together by up to 8 feet
of storm surge nothing was left
unscathed residents here didn't wait for
help to arrive
neighbors with boats and trucks launched
their own rescue efforts going
door-to-door to reach people stranded by
high water how long were you guys in
there
ah 34 hours Jeff Pitts and his dog buddy
were picked up after four feet of storm
surge flooded his home Jeff aunt Donna
said their son went to rescue others
nearby they had personal friends that
are trapped in actually similar but
worse situation deeper water in their
home so they came to my house I got this
boat and they're trying to rescue them
down help is coming in from across the
state I got the call at 4:00 in the
morning to set up and my wife and my two
kids a caravan of fire crews from
Broward and miami-dade County are headed
north to join the emergency teams
already on the ground
PJ Parker and her dog Bodhi are close
behind this is what we work for
this is what we want to do this is what
the dogs want to do those crews from
Broward and miami-dade that we're fixing
other way to fix electricity here they
just came back from hurricane Florence
they're not going to get any rest
they're going from South Carolina over
here to the Florida Panhandle and one
thing they're gonna encounter which is a
lot of people aren't counting here is
trying to get here physically is
difficult not only are there downed
trees big down pine trees in the road
but there are also roads that are washed
out we were actually driving in and
around Port Saint Joe trying to get out
and luckily we stopped because it was
probably about a 15-foot section of road
there was no longer there that's
something that they're gonna need help
with if they're gonna try to get the
power on eventually to this area John
Omar Villafranca thank goodness you
stopped Omar